Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
So as you know,  we have a podcast  'Dear Hank and John'
or as I prefer to think of it 'Dear John and Hank'
And on that podcast, I recently confessed that instead of pouring milk on my cereal, I use water.
Now Nerdfighteria is generally a very supportive community, but their condemnation of my cereal eating habits was swift and nearly universal.
People sent in scientific studies supposedly proving you're supposed to eat cereal with milk
And then there was this vine which recreated one person's experience of eating cereal with water
But along the way, Hank, I learned there is a secret community of people like me out there.
According to one study, 13% of Americans put coffee in their cereal.
Another 12% use orange juice.
I've even heard of some people who use lemon-lime gatorade
So today I'm going to taste test all of the ways of moistening cereal.
Which cereal? Well I chose Raisin Bran, because it toes the line between healthy and delicious
I mean you know it's healthy, because it has 'bran' in the title,
but you know it's delicious because it has more calories, sugar, and sodium than 'Lucky Charms'.
Speaking of which, I also picked up some Lucky Charms, because it turns out it's healthy.
Okay, first off we have Raisin Bran mixed with delicious, safe American tap water.
Note: only 'safe and delicious' in certain jurisdictions.
Ah, it's so good, I just love Raisin Bran with water, it is delicious.
That is just absolutely magnificent, five raisins.
Next up, we're gonna mix our Raisin Bran with some Florida orange juice.
Oh...No...NO!
Two great ingredients, that when mixed together just turn out horribly.
For me, the orange juice is one raisin out of five, even that's a little generous.
Ok, up third: Raisin Bran with Lemon Lime Gatorade.
In general, I'm a big Gatorade fan, and because I'd just had the orange juice
it was so much better by comparison that it was almost "good",
But it still wasn't good: 2 raisins out of 5.
Fourth up, hot black coffee straight from my AFC Wimbledon mug, into the Raisin Bran!
I gotta say, for me this tasted almost exclusively like coffee, and not at all like Raisin Bran
But whatever! I like coffee, and it's fine in bran form. 3 raisins out of 5!
And then lastly, we have Raisin Bran mixed with cow's milk.
Agh! It's just disgusting! It's so rich, it tastes like I'm eating cake or something! I just - That's not Breakfast!
I'm gonna give milk 2 raisins out of 5.
By the way, Sarah just built a Louvre out of Legos
And then Henry and I attacked it with a clone army!
So there you have it, Hank. According to a scientific study of my taste buds, the best liquid  to pour on your Raisin Bran is water.
Followed in order by coffee, lemon lime Gatorade, that stuff that comes out of the nether regions of a cow,  and orange juice.
Now Hank, you said on the podcast that you tried cereal with water, and you didn't like it - you're a milk guy
So we have an intractable disagreement.
But I think we're gonna continue to respect each other and collaborate anyway, and there may be a lesson in that.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.